[تصفيق]
بعد حصول الجمهوريه كبن مكارثي على مطرقه
رئاسه مجلس النواب اثر صفقه ثلاث مفاوضات
شاقه مع اعضاء في حسبه تطرح عده تساؤلات
حول التنازلات التي قدمها
تناز
كبيره كقبوله بشرط اقصى اليمين المتعلق
بطلب اي مشرع اقالته لكنه لم يرى بدا منها
ليفوز بجوله الاختراع الخامسه عشر ما عكس
اختلالا كبيرا وصفا بانه اعمق خلل نظيفي
في الكونغرس منذ 160 عاما
والجيش
على تقديم اقتراح لعزل الرئيس يجعل مكافي
بالتاكيد اكثر ضعفا الى حد ما لكن هذا
الاقتراح لا يزال بحاجه الى اصوات اخرى
والى تمريره باغلبيه الحاضرنا في التصويت
شروط تقييد ايضا لسلطه
مثل تمويل الحكومه وسقف الدين وشملت زياده
نفوذ النوابي في صياغه التشريعات واقرارها
وزياده مقاعد لجنه قواعد مجلس النواب
واعطاء تفويض اثنتين و 70 ساعه لمناقشه
مشاريع القوانين قبل التصويت عليها الى
جانب محاوله تقييد عدد فترات خدمه الاعضاء
في مجلس النواب
والشيوخيه ضيقه عليه ان يجمع جميعا تماما
كما فعلت السيده في روسيا خلال العامين
الماضيين اعتقد انه مع التنازلات التي تم
تقديمها والتي تسمح باجراء تعديلات من
الحضور لدى اعضاء المجلس القدره على
التاثير
بكار في شدد في خطابه بعد الفوز على ان
المجلس في ظل رئاسته سيتصدى لتحديات
امريكا طويله المدى والديون لصعود الحزب
الشيوعي الصينيه وتعهد بوقف ما وصفه
بالانفاق المشرف في واشنطن
فيما يقلل نواب الجمهورينا من اهميه
تنازلات مكارثي مدركينا بانه لولاها لم
استطاع استماره 14 نائبا ليصوت له يتخوفها
اخرون من انها تترك البلاد خلال العامين
المقبلين
رهينه بيد اليمين المتطرف حسين الطاوض
العربيه واشنطن